ces neuf tonnes de pandore d'arrangement
possible
what échappent bien avance georges flow
est bien à vendre les kings au début des
années 90 los angeles a connu ses
premières grandes émeutes raciales ici
en 65 dans le quartier populaire droite
maxime enders qui a grandi à watts a été
profondément marqué par ces quelques
jours de soulèvement
un soulèvement qui commence pourtant
avec un simple contrôle routier
jeudi soir quand un incident banal a
déclenché toute la sphère l'arrestation
d'un jeune noir pour conduite en état
d'ébriété
aussitôt c'est l'attroupement ce sont
les accusations de brutalité qui plus
est toutes parts il faut dire qu'à
l'époque le et lippi dit le corps de
police de la ville qui majoritairement
blancs il est réputé pour sa brutalité
envers les afro-américains 65 durant les
émeutes
c'est la première fois que massa y voit
de ses propres yeux des noirs se
rebellait aussi farouchement contre la
police mais même si à ce moment là la
destruction et sans précédent 35
millions de dollars de dommages
même s'il ya 34 morts plus de 1000
blessés les émeutes amène peu de
changements
la preuve ces images 26 ans plus tard de
rené king en afro américains en train de
se faire tabasser à coups de bâton de
métal par quatre policiers bhl quand les
quatre officiers sont acquittés en appel
92 des centaines d'habitants de los
angeles surtout des afro américains et
des latinos qui est brûle ce qui se
trouve autour de gust à rennes pouvait
voir les flammes juste à côté
il a même cru un moment de nick sa
maison celle où il habite encore aller y
passer
le problème d'après lui c'est que et en
65 et en 92
les afro américains ont détruit leur
propre quartier ils se sont pénalisés
eux mêmes d'une certaine façon parce
qu'il craignait des représailles encore
pire s'ils allaient dans des quartiers
blancs alors qu'au cours des derniers
jours on a vu des manifestants partout à
los angeles y compris à santa monica où
à beverly hills des milieux beaucoup
plus aisé il mouvements et beaucoup plus
diversifiée qu'avant des milliers de
manifestants blanc condamne ce qu'il
tolérait ou ignorés il ya quelques
dizaines d'années et pour ma sai
c'est la clé pour que les choses
changent enfin
si laurence partie radio canada à los
angeles